うんやるまあいろんな vr やると思いますペースで4の vr 回しスマート
フォンの vr も rvr ってそのつけると麻生世界現実とは違う世界に行って
いるこの感覚が味わえるのでちょっとで観客がおかしくなる気がする
なんで今回は僕が vr を付けて感覚がくすみ出るカーカップがおかしくなっじゃぞ
やろうと思います
名付けもし
vr をつけた僕があちらの世界に入っちゃったら怖いはどうするのか
いや怖いですよ実際プレイ r ってわかんないですからねスマホにつけているであっ
たんですけどこれが現実だ場所現実世界の区別がつかなくなったらそこで終わりです
からポンちゃん持ってくれますが今回はそう思ってられた人ですとが深くない vr を
やりすぎて現実世界であったら向こうの世界に持ってかれた人間
で現実世界に意識はなくもう仮想世界向こうの世界に意識がいってしまっててこの世界
で僕の誰も知らない理由
僕の亡骸だけがそこに残っている状態で鋼兵はどうやってここを現実世界でも年のか
またば放置するかもしれませんね
そこは勘弁ですけど vr 2 vr をつけて僕が部壕の世界に持ってかれた時の
後輩の反応が見てみようと思います
心配してくれると思いますよ最近ずっとファイナルファンタジーやってるからねあっつ
の世界に持ってくれてもおかしくない早速抜こうと世界にことでは
湯加減どういう加減のブーツ
[音楽]
明日が盛ってる10年車ああいうのは許さない事前にずに行く
65人あるぞ
早い夏
山にあると思う多分
2やっぱりかっこ悪いいや女らしいよこれ
[音楽]
大やばいマジでヤバイマジでは寄れますだこれ
うわぁおろしましたこれまでましょう着です
えっバージかぁあああああそっワッシャーよああああ
多くよ
尿ファイルがたらです
栗すげーバックはリールの花も綺麗なずう
あそこのスタッフは7坂戸すっすごいよ
やばいパークに七宝古き良き
昔の
海底だよ
多分
彼は笑っているが
このときすでに始め
仮想世界に魂が移動してしまっているのだ
笑っている場合じゃない
今の初めにどれだけ話しかけでも
彼が答えることはないだろう
そう
彼は今
ただ亡骸になってしまったのである
s 版をもっと出してはいない
なっ
写真を撮ってる場合でもない笑っている場合ではないターゲットははじめを起こそうと
いろいろ試してみたのだ
どれも効果がなかったん
なぜなら今の始めには
魂がないから
そういう
システム
どういうシステムなのだ
あ
うバレてしまうやられたやれたなんか光ってるのあるんですけどやられたぞーっ
ジャガー
カメラを見つけたところで
はじめに魂が戻ってくることはなかった
引き続きいろいろ試してみたが
ハズレが魂が戻ることはなかったッ
ああ奇跡的に一瞬魂が戻ったような
その後も色々試したらああ
はずみが起きることはなかった
彼は何をしているのだろうか
そして彼はシンガー前の時間が来て
楽しいが抜けたたちから奪ったはず日お部屋に放置し
帰ったのであったん
うんっ
me
ええええええ
[音楽]
バッハ